[Musik]
noch bis halb drei nachts geschlossen
8 vollständig von der zeit zum
frühstücken sich ein gericht die
verfügung
doch gar nicht
reformiert werden
wachsende von dem event einen kompletten
was seine ersten bühnenerfahrungen bevor
der erfolg würde ich sagen ja
jemand wie hohn sagt wasser hängen für
dich jetzt eine ganze zeit über zwölf
jahren hat für die angefangen und geübt
hätten
ich habe angefangen mit youtube
nein
euro
ich habe gerade bei importeuren
donnerstag wird was mir mag man eben
limited edition erwartet kraft erlebnis
einer videowand gesehen ich bin
unterwegs wird
andere die haben ihre getroffen und
hi
[Applaus]
entwickler to mark foto
hallo
der ganze abend erker an werke anfängern
luca wieder später weg richtig weh genug
sind ja auch später losgefahren als wir
wollten wegen wieder nicht
ihren stil inside geschäftsführung fühlt
sich so an als chef von seinem habe
es sei nicht ein reifen die wir ab ganz
so schlimm
stimmt wir gerade im nh hotel in meinem
essen diesen haben ha ist an der oper
ist zurück von treffen waren wir gott
gewehr nach kurzer was essen und werden
jetzt auch die aftershow gehen die
patienten dort über film werden
[Musik]
schon am morgen gern mal 1050 sagen wir
uns in einem blog wieder
[Musik]